PRESENTER: Welcome to
this episode of UXD.
This is the last episode
of a three part series
where I share best practices
for designing and building
location-based mobile apps
that are sure to delight
smartphone users
who are on the go.
In this episode, we'll focus on
the design implications driven
by the constraints placed on
users and their smartphones
due to environmental conditions.
I'm your host, Nazmul
Idris, a developer
advocate passionate
about design and mobile.
In part one, I talked about
the importance of understanding
user context for
location based apps.
Typically research
and planning tasks
are done on tablets and
laptops, and smartphones
tend to be used on the
go for execution tasks.
Now, users on the go tend to be
quite busy doing other things
and can be really distracted.
So not only do we have to take
the human hand into account,
and optimize the interaction
design for single handed use,
but we also have to be
human brain into account.
So in part two, I
talked about how
you can make location
information on maps
graceful and easy to
consume for users on the go.
Now I'll talk about
environmental factors that
are outside the user and
their smartphone, which
have a huge impact on
the type of experience
that they're going to get from
their location-based apps.
In other words,
we're going to talk
about building and
designing applications
for the real world.
So when users are on
the go, chances are,
they might be outside.
And if they need to
glance at some information
on their phones,
then outside lighting
becomes a huge factor
on whether they'll
be able to read this
information in the first Place.
In fact, I mean you have to read
it in order process it, right?
So if it's really bright
and sunny outside,
and the UI uses very
subtle gradients
with similar colors and low
contrast between foreground
and background that
allow the user to discern
the boundaries between
objects and layers,
then all this will be lost.
In fact, all the subtlety which
probably took a lot of effort
to create and tune, will
just be pulling washed away,
and the user will not
be able to see much,
because of the lack of contrast,
which would be a shame.
So keep this in mind
when you're thinking
about glanceable information
for users on the go.
UX design is all about
industrial design
utility and not the fine arts.
You must also make sure that
font size and images are large.
Most countries where
smartphone users prevalent
have an increasingly
aging population.
This means that you have to
be mindful of whether the UI
that your handcrafting
to perfection
is just too small for someone
with even less ideal vision
to even see.
And finally, brevity
is key in delivering
content to users
who are on the go.
People are distracted.
They're doing other
things in the real world.
So keep it short.
It's much more difficult to
make something short and useful
than to ramble on.
So put in the work
to make this happen.
Keep in mind when you're
thinking about information
to display to the user.
Prioritize on their behalf.
When you know that
they're on the go,
and they'll thank you for this.
But also give a way to get more
information if they wanted.
So one of the biggest
environmental factors
that can affect
the user experience
is the type of connectivity
that's available to the user
right now.
And we've all
experienced cellular
that cellular and Wi-Fi
connectivity can vary greatly
from one location to the next.
And again, this
is especially true
for users are out and about.
One minute you have a
great network coverage,
and the next minute you might
have little to no coverage,
and then back to
great coverage again.
So depending on when
the user interacts
with your application,
they might
be delighted or
utterly disappointed.
Now there's a right of
reasons why cover changes.
There might be a lack
of cell towers thereby.
There might be a lack of
Wi-Fi access points nearby.
And there might be
wireless signal congestion.
For example, in a
packed conference.
Or it could be occlusion, which
is when you go through a tunnel
or you're in an elevator.
And there's like a
variety of other reasons
why connectivity
could be spotty.
Now, a great way
to manage this is
to ensure that your
location-based app has
offline mode.
Gmail for Android is a
shining example of this.
It hides whether you're online
or offline from the user
entirely.
In fact, you can compose
emails without connectivity.
And these are just
queued for delivery,
but are actually sent when
Gmail has connectivity.
So now you can view
emails and attachments
that you've already
downloaded to the device
without any network as well.
You just have to figure out,
for your application, which
we use cases are
critical, and ensure
that there's an offline
mode and in online
mode design and implementation
for those use cases
Now, these use cases should
execute without any network
coverage, using only local
resources on the device,
and when connectivity
is restored,
this content should be
synced to whatever back
end services you need.
All this happening without
the knowledge of the user.
It's important to note that
offline mode isn't important,
just because wireless
connectivity can be unreliable.
It might also be the user's
choice to be in offline mode
to preserve their data plane.
It's irresponsible restaurant
for developers and designers
to assume that all users
have unlimited data plans.
Cellphones and data plans
as cost a lot of money,
and there's a lot of
different constituents
if you look at the demographics
for smartphone users.
So there's another reason why
it's really important for you
to truly understand the user
if your application or product.
You should do the
UX research that's
needed to understand
your user, so you
can get an idea of
how important it
is they could not
wreck their data plan.
Now, this could be one
of the key features that
makes your application more
attractive to a certain set
of users.
So again, do your user research,
and make informed decisions.
When you start talking
about offline mode,
prefetching and caching
can't be far behind.
Caching is something that you
should do as often as you can.
And it's something
that can be done
with very little development
cost in most cases.
So there's little
excuse not to do this.
Once you've downloaded
any data over the network,
you should try and save
this to local storage,
in case your user
might need it again.
So as they go back
through the floor,
fill out your application, the
information is already there.
Cache also ensures that the
user see some data, which
is better than no data, even
if that information stale.
So on that note, make sure
to invalidate and refresh
your cache, as it makes
sense in the context
of your location-based
application.
The Google Play
Music app on Android
does a great job of this.
It catches any played music
on the devices local storage,
so that when you go back
to play that music again,
it's already on the device.
And it does not have
to be downloaded
and streamed over the network,
costing precious bandwidth.
Prefetching is a slightly
more difficult thing
to implement than caching.
But there are many
situations where
it can deliver tremendous
value to the user,
especially for
location-based apps.
It makes it so that as the user
flows through your application,
as they move
forward, prefetching
takes care of making sure
that information is available
before they need it.
Now, caching helps the
user go back smoothly
through your application,
and prefetching
helps them move
forwards more smoothly.
What am I talking about?
So let's say you have
a have an application,
and you've geofenced
the location.
Now let's say that your
user enters this fence.
This might sugar application
to prefetch some information
that they're likely
to need very soon.
And when the user
actually tries to access
this information
in the near future,
they'll be delighted when this
information shows up instantly.
Because from their perspective,
there was no lag or delay.
There were no loading screens.
Magic happen in the
information was there
before they needed it.
How awesome is that?
So from the user's perspective,
again, load times are bad.
And you want the information
to show up instantly.
And it's all about
managing perception.
So the actual performance isn't
so important from a user's
perspective, as the
perception of that performance
or perceived performance.
Now, the Google Maps Navigation
is great at doing this.
Before you start
navigating to a route,
it downloads a fair
amount of routing data,
so that if there are
glitches in connectivity
while you're moving, it
won't impact the directions
that the app provides
with, which is awesome.
It could even reroute you
without network connectivity
on the journey, which
is even awesomer.
This is a really,
really important thing,
because when users are
actually on the go,
they have no patience for
connectivity issues bubbling
into the user experience.
So that's all the time we
have this for this episode.
Keep these three things in mind.
The user's hand, the
user's attention,
the environmental
conditions that
affect the user of the
device, and this well
I need to build great
location-based experiences
on mobile.
And also remember, that
these constraints are not
compromises.
Without constraints, this would
go from UX industrial design
to the fine arts.
However, creating a
design and implementation
that violates these
constraints will certainly
compromise the experience of
your product for your user.
If you haven't already,
please be sure to join our UX
community on Google+.
It's a place where we can
continue this discussion
and meet other people who are
just as passionate about user
experience as you are.
Thanks for watching and goodbye.